robot knee is an indoor vertical farming
technology company using automated
robotics and software analytics / the
internet-of-things vertical farms are
able to grow plants indoors 24/7 365
with optimal growing conditions a lot of
the current vertical farming operations
do have a few key problems namely
they're very inefficient a lot of wasted
labour effort a lot of wasted space our
robots and our software we bring plants
to the workers will allow for the first
ever human free grow room on a
commercial scale it's very exciting and
you know vertical farming is the future
and Rabbani is the future of vertical
farming
I think Carnegie Mellon attracts
entrepreneurs and artists alike because
of its quirkiness it's such a quirky
University you have robots and bagpipes
and opera singers it's also cross campus
and collaborative so it's it's not as
siloed as you think it would be I think
that that quirkiness that's very
important the Support Center is a great
place because with all the resources at
Carnegie Mellon it's all being put under
one roof and that's amazing because
instead of having to go a million
different places you can go a one-stop
shop and so you can literally go to the
entire campus just by going to the
Sports Center and that's where everybody
is and that's where access that support
and advice you need while also meeting
all you know your future your future
code matters I believe that what we're
doing will change the world
and I think that Carnegie Mellon and
Robotnik and the greater CMU and
Pittsburgh community share a common
mission and that is to enhance the human
condition
you